are you more of an artist or businessman
these days these days definitely more of
a businessman yeah sure so talk to me
about lighting Africa you want to
Electrify a million homes as the goal
yeah actually when we first started the
idea was to light up a million homes but
now we're in 14 countries so we've
weighed but in a group surpassed our
goal like being on and now we're moving
towards global you know investment
sooner but but you're not I mean you
don't think of yourself as a non-profit
you were doing this to make money
oh yeah no clearly a car lighting out
for this for profit I think I got mixed
up in the nonprofit because everyone
kept saying it's an initiative on a
level of because it's doing so much good
for Africa itself they assumed that it
was a you know nonprofit and not too
many artists you know kind of get into
energy without you know I mean yeah
creating a some kind of you know charity
um billion billion dollar fund you're
raising that with credit suisse you've
just started how his demand been oh man
listen I mean it's been so amazing
because ultimately with in January now I
mean like I said we're in 14 countries
you know his contract signed so it was
pretty easy to get them involved and
they were really excited and doing a lot
of stuff in Africa so it was pretty easy
to put it together so now the demand for
is really high when you talk to are you
talking to sovereign wealth funds you
have Chinese investments do you have
United Arab Emirates investment where's
where's the money coming from well you
know there's been a lot of Chinese
coming in on board because we're doing a
lot in Africa as well too
but they're creating on some private and
sovereign investments as well talk to
doctors about the challenges of Ebola
you're obviously also doing an
initiative with Matt Damon Morgan
Freeman where are we
well of course their boat is more about
raising the awareness because I think
our biggest challenge when it comes to
Ebola is that there's so much lack of
education related to it no one really
knows what it is how to cure it you know
how it really affects tomorrow so
ultimately is trying to raise that voice
and get everybody more involved in
understanding what it is
can figure out a way to actually delete
it is there an economic component as
well I think it's more social than
anything at this point and how it's
being projected I think it's more so we
can help to delete the scare because
normally when your script afraid of
something you don't to get closer to it
so my purpose is even born again and
during that time it's a no understand it
better so I can practically you know
give the message out to the people that
follows what I'm doing now we just saw
you get mobbed earlier got a lot of fans
you have you met with any young
entrepreneurs here and what are you
hearing from them I don't know I mean
especially on a digital side there's a
lot of them here there's a lot of young
entrepreneurs going into agriculture as
well too but I mean I'm meeting a lot
that's more on the digital tomorrow like
that wave of you know how the digital is
actually affecting Africa will now
leapfrog literally into the future with
the technology final question what's the
prospect for agriculture you're starting
in rice in Senegal where else you're
gonna branch out to we want to branch
off to everywhere where there's official
lights because a lot of these areas
where we're concentrating on is the
rural areas and those areas after
certain amount of time you really can't
do anything especially relating to
agriculture for that matter so we want
to follow our steps wherever we're
putting lights we want to actually have
areas where we're putting in a lot of
Agriculture cuz as you know Africa when
it comes to any punch is very rich ok
well thank you very much I wish you the
best of luck I thought we were talking
to a hip-hop artist but indeed we're
talking to a one man holding company
with a lot of ventures in Africa he can
get on board now he's raising money for
that